what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the mighty morphin power
rangers yes we are and this
is the origin of lord drakken who's
probably one of the coolest characters
ever created in the history of the power
rangers mythos so if you guys recall the
last video that we did
basically the dragon zord or the zord
itself of lord drakken had more or less
been defeated but tommy and billy were
kind of caught inside of it and then
ultimately teleported away to this
alternate reality where lord drakken had
came into power and so what we end up
getting here
is a really really cool origin now
before we jump into it instead
as billy and tommy are sort of roaming
around here and trying to figure out
what's going on they actually end up in
this kind of museum that talks about how
rita repulsa had come to power had
already pulsa and and really lord
drakken sort of run everything but it
really seems to be more rita than
anything else
it's pretty ambiguous for them because
they don't really understand exactly
what's going on right it's like i mean
this is
this place is in shambles like how did
it get to this point
right angel grove is quite literally
just ripped to pieces but in the middle
of trying to figure it all out
suddenly they're met by the arrival of
what is basically a cop who looks like
the black ranger and that's kind of
crazy thing because from there like it's
like they recognize this tommy
has the uh has the flute for the dragon
zord right and it's kind of like okay
this guy's got a dragon dagger like what
in the world
is going on here right they immediately
pursue these guys and so the the idea of
billy is okay
let's go to angel grove high school
right like you know it's a familiar
place
at the very least we can hide out we can
just kind of give ourselves a momentary
reprieve
obviously they're not going to stay
there forever the problem is as soon as
they get there the entire place
has basically been turned into a
correctional facility that really seems
to be ran by fenster right and so it's
kind of like wow you know and then of
course
all those uh those ranger cops more or
less show up and this leads billy and
tommy and gives them a chance to
basically escape right jumping in the
water and then just kind of getting as
far away as they possibly can
and so while lord drackett is notified
by these cops
essentially billy and tommy end up
making their way to the command center
that was the power rangers and when they
get there
the whole place is wrecked i mean it's
decimated right like
zords are all over the place the funny
thing is some of the lords are the ones
that haven't even shown up yet in the in
the power rangers comics technically
they've shown up in the actual show in
mighty wolf and power rangers and we'll
explain them here in a second and so
it's kind of a crazy thing here because
once billy gets up there and really once
tommy gets up there and they're kind of
asking that they're kind of looking
around they're like oh man this must
have been some kind of a crazy question
this disembodied voice seemingly comes
out of nowhere and says yeah it was a
vicious battle indeed right it's crazy
and when they both realize this is a
voice they've heard the voice kind of
directs them down
into the basement of the command center
now this is an amazing moment right it's
one of the one of the coolest things
those are guys who are long-standing
power rangers fans are gonna absolutely
love this right so
as they're talking to it it's a little
bit suspicious because they don't really
know exactly who the voice is coming
from
but it is coming from someone right
somewhere and so tommy
is who's obviously and really always has
been a little more
brave sometimes foolish and certainly
more reckless than somebody like billy
who's more calculating just kind of
dives down there and it's like this guy
knows who we are right so at the very
least if he means to attack us there's
not much we can do to stop him so at the
very least we can go kind of figure out
what's going on here and so once they
get down there and tommy's just kind of
okay like how do i get to you we end up
finding out he's basically in the
basement of the command center and
there's this sealed door
and this guy kind of promises you know
to essentially tell tommy everything he
wants to know right to answer all his
questions and so he ultimately ends up
prying the door open only to find out
it's saba
right or seba depending on how you want
to pronounce it i always called him saba
basically
the sword of the white ranger right and
that's the craziest thing because it's
like damn dude the sword of the white
rangers here
as soon as i saw that i was like what
now of course around the same time this
happens everything pops off right you
basically like you got lord dracula
shows up here with with you know a whole
host of forces and so on and kind of
starts intimidating
uh billy and tommy now here's the thing
draken looks amazing and i've always
loved the way he looks right i've always
loved the design of his character he
looked
awesome and it's kind of a crazy thing
because where he kind of talks to tommy
and even sort of
makes fun of him a little bit and kind
of gives him a hard time this statement
tommy makes is like we're not going to
lay down here but you don't know you
have no idea who you're dealing with
here and he's like actually i do tommy
you're nothing more than my lesser self
right and that's when it's basically
kind of revealed
that lord drakken is actually tommy from
an alternate reality right like an
alternate universe and that's
crazy right that was nuts when that
first came out because it was like damn
what happened that tommy basically
conquered the world like what in the
heck happened here now because of the
fact that that i guess you could call
him main tommy right good tommy
essentially
what we'll do here is we'll call good
tommy tommy and we'll call the evil
tommy lord dragon since that's really
his proper name anyway right so tommy's
just kind of like okay look so
this is kind of crazy right like you're
not me and and dragon's like yeah you're
right man i'm not you
i'm a better you and so initially they
intend to take them but saba kind of
comes to the rescue and actually summons
the white tiger sword right now
there's not a whole lot this lord can do
as you guys can tell this thing is
absolutely crushed but it's designed to
be a distraction more so than anything
else
and when that goes down and the white
tigers literally just kind of rampaging
you know draken's telling his guys fire
up the cannons tear this thing apart
that what you end up getting is saba who
basically leads uh tommy and billy to
the falcon zord which
isn't necessarily completely defunct
it's got enough energy to where it can
get them out of there but it's not quite
its former self right doesn't why it
really doesn't really possess the same
level
of power as it used to but it does allow
billy and tommy to ultimately escape and
get away now
once they get to a bit of a resting
place there's a couple things that go on
here the first isabella basically tells
them this zord is not fully powered
right it's been sitting it's been
dormant for a long long time
it needs some geothermal energy to
basically get itself going again right
to get its power
back up to where it's supposed to be but
at the very least we're in a relatively
safe place we also end up learning
they're in the woods of the coinless
basically
individuals who are part of what's in
effect a resistance force that are
trying to fight against lord drakken
which is
an awesome concept but he also basically
spills the beans on how lord drakken
became lord drakken in the first place
and this is amazing i'm going to tell
you guys right now it's one of the most
exciting things right i love origin
stories for alternate reality versions
of characters who are twisted and evil
and as a guy who's been reading comics
for decades i gotta say this is one of
the best written origin stories that i
think i've ever seen
the way that saba explains this is that
all of this started with the arrival of
the green ranger right with the arrival
of tommy now much like in the main
universe for power rangers that when
tommy first showed up on the scene he
had basically been hoodwinked by by rita
repulsa right operating under her
control
fighting against the power rangers just
like what we saw before he beat the crap
out of the power rangers because all the
power rangers suck in comparison to the
power of the green ranger and so he
overcame seemingly all of them
the big difference here is that in the
main power rangers universe when tommy
was defeated and the power rangers
really approached him
with friendship as opposed to hostility
that this led to the green ranger
essentially you know being freed from
rita repulsa's mind control and then
ultimately joining the power rangers
because they offered him that olive
branch
the same process happened here the
difference is that tommy stood against
them he said no i don't want to join you
guys i don't want to have anything to do
with you guys and so what he ended up
doing was actually going back with rita
repulsa and one of the big differences
here the way this is kind of explained
is that where zordon was always
stressing this idea
that defense and unification was
necessary to protect the world not only
from any
threats that may exist out there but
protect the world from destroying itself
that rita on the other hand was still
largely being manipulative and had
pitched this idea and explained this id
to tommy that the only way to save the
world
was to basically destroy the world and
to remake it if humanity was going to
get it together it already would have
the fact that it hasn't shows that it
doesn't want to and so if the world's
not gonna not gonna fix itself then
somebody will fix the world for them
right and that's what rita repulsa did
that when she showed up on the scene
with like goldar and with the green
ranger tommy and with all the putties
and everything that over the course of
years they literally just conquer those
like huge sections of the world now the
question you're probably asking yourself
is what were the power rangers doing
during
this time and one of the things to
understand is that at this point in time
the power rangers were largely still a
relatively small faction and so
when you're facing off against like this
mountain of putties and you're facing
off against the green ranger in goldar
what it really seemed to turn into with
the power rangers was guerrilla warfare
tactics pot shots that's all it really
seemed to be right just
showing up here showing up there trying
to defend where they could when they
could but there wasn't really a whole
lot they could do against such an
overwhelming force and so the way it's
explained is that cities burned leaders
gave in
and it says apologists made excuses
right that apologists were like well i
mean she's not gonna rule us forever
guys i mean you know we can kind of give
in
a little bit you know i mean it's okay
people who were basically you know who
just didn't really have a backbone what
you actually found
is by virtue of the message that rita
repulsa was putting out
one between her own propaganda and two
the people she was conquering and
temporarily
and kind of you know in a manipulative
fashion improving their lives you
actually began to see people who
embraced the rule of rita repulsa and
that's one of the most important things
here it's not enough for a person to
kind of step in and conquer things what
you need
is to get people to your side what you
have to do is sway the people to your
cause
conquer everything and then shift things
up and then put them in a position to
where even if they could fight back
there's no real way
for them to fight back or no real
meaningful way for them to fight back
right that's how you conquer a country
that's how you take over an entire
territory and so in response to this
what you had was essentially
a last-ditch effort in what became known
as the fall of the rangers and this was
a combination of all these different
things coming together the big kicker to
all this is that unlike in the normal
mighty morphin power rangers timeline
well the white ranger was created as
kind of the next evolution
of what power rangers were harnessing
the white light things like that in this
instance it was an act of desperation it
was the idea of okay we're gonna harness
everything that's good in the world and
we're going to basically channel it
directly into a ranger and make this
person the most powerful of all the
rangers that have seemingly ever existed
on earth there are a couple things to
kind of keep in mind here for example
you do have the alien power rangers for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
that was actually a story arc that took
place in the mighty morphin power
rangers tv show when the main power
rangers themselves were de-aged by the
father of rita rapulsa and then in turn
zordon had to grab alien rangers and
bring them in kind of temporarily until
the power rangers were aged back up and
then they went back to doing their thing
again but this whole idea right ninja
the guy who basically helped the power
rangers become ninjas because the movie
sucked and nobody wants that to be in
continuity
all these allies had basically banned
together in what was by all standards of
measurement the last battle at the alamo
right that's really what it was the
final stand like if we fall here
everything falls there's no possible way
that we can we can defend beyond this
all the zords the whole nine yards right
it's all it's all brought in right this
is two seconds left in the game
it's it's fourth and 30 because they're
they're terrible they're at like the
70-yard line
right on the opposition side like at
this point it's a hail mary pass right
that's exactly what this is it's all
right every every receiver just
run forward that way and we're just
gonna lob this ball as hard as we can
and pray to god we get a touchdown and
they
don't right as soon as like like this
whole thing is crazy right the green
ranger
goldar scorpina the whole nine yards
like they're all here and just descend
on this on on the command center and
it's like a battle for the
ages right i mean it's crazy like all
these different versions of the power
rangers are all fighting
fighting against these guys as best as
they possibly can the only person who's
the holdout here
is jason because jason was chosen as the
guy to become the white ranger and so
while while they're basically trying to
power him up and essentially get him to
a point where the morphing process is
possible right where he can actually
morph
in and out of the white ranger in that
moment tommy breaks into the command
center and so the entire process
is interrupted what it ultimately comes
down to is a fight between jason and
tommy
essentially for the future of the world
right if we're being honest with
ourselves it's not just a fight between
these two guys it's a fight to save
the world that's really all it is and
literally tommy tells jason like this is
your last shot man like either you can
ally with the side of rita repulsa or
you can die and of course jason's like
no right i'm never going to ally with
rita and he's like okay fine then about
that new power and ultimately tommy gets
the upper hand on jason
seemingly kills him when he comes out of
the of the command center
with jason's helmet and like that's it
right he's basically merged himself with
the power of the right ranger
and that's how lord drakken became lord
drakken when he's a merger between the
green and the white ranger
and that's the crazy thing is because at
that point saba just kind of finishes
the story and says that was the
beginning of the end and the big
question they have here is
then why weren't you captured how do you
fit into all of this and the answer is
that if lord drakken were to ever get
his hands on
saba that it would it would seemingly
just kind of solidify his role because
as of right now he's more or less just
kind of a blend between the white and
the green ranger but without saba he
can't really become
a 100 percent white ranger right he
can't become a complete white ranger but
as soon as he has that sword
his transformation will be complete
right that's basically what'll end up
happening with him and that's why
zordon as this kind of last ditch
movement basically
kept saba hidden down in the basement of
the command center and shut off
anybody's ability to access him or
anybody's ability to know that he's
there
and so he could only basically be woken
up by a person who was pure right he was
kind of kept in hibernation in that way
that was the fail safe and the backup
plan and so when tommy and billy showed
up here
that he could only really be wielded by
a pure person only be woken up by a pure
person
which appears to be tommy the biggest
problem is before they can really get
any definitive information out of this
beyond that suddenly they're ensnared by
this power only to be met by a handful
of different people and who they are
i'm not telling you but i'm going to
tell you right now it's amazing with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching
and i will catch you all later peace